we'll call a meeting to order of the
committee to study medical interventions
and immunizations and we'll start with
the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
so as i did yesterday i i'm you know
this committee is is looking at the
intersections of the shalls and shall
nots
in
existing law or existing department
regulations and how those shall and
shall not intersect with either business
and citizens
to see if again if they're appropriate
if they need strengthening if they need
weakening if they're just not
appropriate and need to be removed um
as well as any gaps that exist in in
current law and regulation that might
need to be addressed
um i will say there are 30 plus bills
that have been entered on the topic of
either masking mandates covid or
vaccinations and though every one of
those bills would get a public hearing
i'm going to just like quickly run
through the list of bills again for
everyone's so everyone knows what topics
are going to be addressed in the
upcoming legislative session
as it may impact or not impact your
testimony i'm just going to be reading
the titles of the bills only
relative to requiring covert
vaccinations for school attendance
relative to the new hampshire attorney
general to empanel a covid grand jury to
investigate events relative to the covet
19 pandemic
relative to the state grants for
researching the effect of the on the
human body of the covid 19 vaccines
eliminating the scratch that one
requiring post-secondary institutions to
accept religious and medical exemptions
from vaccine requirements
requiring an audit of the new hampshire
vaccine association
making the state vaccine registry an
opt-in program
relative to the exemptions from vaccine
mandates relative to the exemption of
school vaccine mandates relative to
students attending public schools that
mandate the wearing of face masks
without an emergency order in place
limiting the authority of the department
of health and human services to mandate
vaccinations and relative to the
quarantine costs
relative state enforcement of federal
vaccination mandates
relative to mandates adopted by
employers
relative to employee protections from
coven 19 in workplace
prohibiting the state and government
from adopting certain mandates in
response to the covet 19 and prohibiting
employers and places of public
accommodation from discriminating
on the basis of vaccine status
vaccination status
relative to the procedure for withdrawal
from the vaccine registry
requiring the department of health and
human services to maintain certain
records relative to the vaccine registry
expanding the prohibition against
discrimination based on individuals
election not to participate in the state
vaccine registry prohibiting department
of health from requiring vaccine
passports for services prohibiting the
higher education institutions receiving
state funds from requiring face masks
and covert 19 vaccinations for
attendance
relative to limited liability or
personal injury resulting
from or related to exposure to covet 19
relative to unemployment benefits for
employees terminated for refusing to
comply with vaccine mandates relative
the enforceability of non-completed
non-compete agreements upon termination
of employee for non-compliance for the
vaccine mandate
relative vaccine mandates for government
contractors relative to financial
responsibility for employer-mandated
covet-19 testing of employees
prohibiting the school district from
priming a school district from mandating
cover 19 vaccination for school
attendance prohibiting certain employers
from requiring covenant vaccine in as a
condition of employment
relative to the eligibility of workers
compensation for adverse reactions to
mandatory covered nineteen vaccinations
requiring full fda approval for of
vaccines relative to covenanting health
and safety policies of the new hampshire
performing arts venues
relative to school district policies on
face mass of school of students in
school
and lastly requiring an independent
audit and needs assessment regarding
covert 19 preparedness and long-term
care facilities nursing homes and a new
hampshire veterans home and making
appropriation thereof so there are the
32 bills that we have currently in front
of the um the that'll be in front of the
state legislature and i'm sure that's
not an exhaustive list at the time i ran
this the senate still had some openings
for time
and i know that there was some
negotiations on rewriting some bills to
consolidate them so there might not be
quite as many
um
so i as that as that relates to your
topic you may just want to know that
those are there
again the goal of this committee is to
look at the shalls and shall nots and
current statute and rules
see where they intersect and relative to
medical interventions and immunization
with our citizenry
so and with that we'll go ahead and is
there anything anything that committee
members want to say before we start
not hearing anything erica if you would
first we'll have david giuve from the
bia
uh congratulations because nobody gets
that last name right
um mr chairman members of the committee
for the record my name is dave giuve i'm
a senior vice president for public
policy with the business and industry
association which serves as new
hampshire's statewide chamber of
commerce and i'm also
in a temporary capacity serving as
interim president while the association
conducts a search for a new president
thank you for the opportunity to be here
this morning i want to focus my comments
specifically on employers and the
workplace and their
ability to
have
a vaccine mandate as a condition of
employment either because they think
it's the right thing to do in terms of
the health and safety of their employees
or if they're complying with federal
vaccine mandates which
many employers in the state uh are
either already having to comply with if
they have federal contracts or will soon
likely be having to comply with once
osha has released their draft rules
relating to the executive order
our position is that
employers
really need to have the flexibility and
ability to implement health and safety
policies within the workplace that they
deem appropriate
and for some employers that
could be a vaccine mandate although i
will say right now
among our membership
those employers who've implemented a
vaccine mandate is
not common it tends to be
among our hospital members and we also
have several manufacturing members
who contract with the federal government
who have very recently implemented
vaccine mandates among their employees
the response from employees in those
companies
has not been overwhelmingly negative
there have been
instances that i'm aware of what of a
one-day employee walk out from those
employees who were not happy with the
new vaccine mandate
but they returned to work the following
day and there have been
little if any
instances of employees
choosing to leave employment because of
the vaccine mandate
we view this as being very similar to
other health and safety mandates that
are already in place either through
federal or state regulation or because
the employee deems its the employee the
employer deems it the appropriate
thing to do for example
most if not all employers require seat
belt use if you're driving a company
vehicle
most employers food services employers
require
some type of hair net if you're in the
all employers in
construction areas require hard hats to
be worn
depending on your job you may be
required to wear an orange safety vest i
could go on and on but the point is
with none of those
requirements does an employee have the
choice to say i'm opting out
i'm a conscientious objector to that and
therefore don't have to do it the
employee is required to follow those
health and safety
requirements set up by the employer and
we think the same thing should be true
with with vaccine mandates
that's all i have mr chair i'd be happy
to address any questions
thank you david uh any questions for
david
representative goalie
thank you mr chair thank you good to see
you there
um
and is it also
appropriate that if a business so
chooses to do a
vaccine mandate for their company um it
may be in the best interest of the
company for to keep
their employees from getting
ill or sick and
having to close down their business it's
a business
um
explore the business
yeah that's a very real concern and
there are a lot of recent examples uh
with the advent of the pandemic
um
i guess part of my response to your
question repsham goalie is a lot of the
discussion relating to this issue is
focused on the individual rights of an
individual to choose whether they want
to be vaccinated or not and i understand
that point of view
but it tends to ignore
the rights of other individuals other
employees to want to work in a
workplace that is as safe and and
healthy as possible
and if uh the employer deems that having
a fully vaccinated workforce is is how
to achieve that
then we should recognize that that there
are employees out there and i suspect
it's the majority of employees at this
point that would support that type of
mandate because they have their own
health and safety and the health and
safety of their family members and
and wouldn't it also be a
benefit to
not losing any income for a business or
having to shut down due to having an
exposure in the place of employment or
for the cost of employees being out of
the workplace ill yeah i can um actually
speak from personal experience some of
you know my wife works for a dentist
office here in town
most of the office is vaccinated several
employees
have chosen not to be vaccinated
and
one of
those employees recently was exposed to
covid and as it turned out she
well she was exposed twice the first
time
it turned out she didn't have it she was
tested and didn't have it the second
time she was tested and she did have it
and it required her to quarantine for i
think 14 days now she was one of two
hygienists in the office
so a hundred percent of the workload
went on to the other hygienist uh in the
real world result was they had to cancel
appointments with patients because they
didn't have the ability
uh because of uh
lack of that employee being there to to
be able to work on the patient so
that's just one example from my own
personal life and i'm sure there are
anybody anybody else
representative leon thank you very much
mr chair and thank you mr juve
i i understand the disruption to the
workforce um i'm wondering if there's
other things that the employers can
mandate in order to prevent
employees for being out for extended
periods like two weeks or longer
there there are um other things that are
already being implemented and really
have been implemented since the start of
the pandemic early last year things like
one significant change which i think is
going to change how businesses run is is
the ability for for some employees to
work from
remote locations or working from home
and i think that's going to change the
way business operates not all jobs are
you're not able to do that with all jobs
uh other things that have been
implemented in the workplace or
expanding
um work areas to account for social
distancing
uh some some uh employers uh
require or request testing of employees
um all employers almost all i would
expect if you're exposed to back uh to a
covid uh
an individual with covid19 there are um
quarantine requirements so there are a
number of ways and i'm not suggesting
that
uh employers want to
uh implement a vaccine mandate so they
can do away with those other
things i think everything contributes to
reducing the transmission of covet 19 in
the workplace
okay thank you and um with that it is a
significant impact to business
operations to have a employee out for a
time period like that yes
i talked to a recent manufacturer
who
uh interestingly the conversation
started because they had con they're a
manufacturer of more than 100 employees
and they're anticipating being under the
requirement of the uh presidential
executive order and they had a lot of
concerns about that
um
and in this particular workplace i'd ask
them well how are you
dealing with with the pandemic now and
he says well we're not really
taking a position one way or the other
we're allowing our employee employees to
make their own decisions about this
and i said well how's that going he goes
well we've we've had instances of
[Music]
employees getting coveted 19 and being
out he also said they had two employees
who have died from covet 19 related
reasons
so
it certainly impacts employers in
some ways in the worst ways possible
and so with that you you believe that it
is appropriate to require a medical
intervention for a patient that extends
past working hours that prevents those
disruptions to business
um i
honestly am not an expert on medical
interventions what i'm requesting this
committee to consider
is giving employers the the ability
to
implement uh health uh health and safety
measures that they deem appropriate for
their workplace
okay so with that you would it would be
appropriate for an employer in a tight
labor market with a hard time getting
employees to require their female
employees to be on birth control in
order to prevent the disruption because
that's also a disruption to the business
that is something that i don't think any
employer i've ever heard of even
considering so
it's
it
it's just i can't even respond to that
because it's it's just not
we also hadn't considered this sort of
thing in the past before of most uh
um
and and also i guess my last question is
this is not a sterilizing vaccine and to
the people who are worried about the
reproductive issues that's not what i
mean scientifically a sterilizing
vaccine is one that prevents
transmission and while we know it
reduces it it doesn't prevent it
entirely so you believe that
having a vaccine something that they
can't take off at the end of the shift
like you would with a hard hat or a seat
belt is an appropriate request for the
employees
i believe employers should have the
ability to implement
health and safety measures that they
deem in the best interest of the health
and safety of their employees and the
workplace and honestly representative if
an employee feels that strongly about it
they will
would have to find other employment if
they don't qualify for a medical or a
religious exemption
thank you
thank you david anybody else i have a
couple questions so so david i just want
to make sure i understand part of what
you're saying and just rephrase it and
see if i'm clear but
um it sounds like it's you're not um
you just want employees to have the
flexibility either to or not to right
that you don't think it should be a
mandate across the entire organization
and industry but you're the flexibility
for an individual employer to decide
whether or not it's good for their
business
and be able to implement if they choose
is that is that your testimony correct
and if i could add to that
uh some
with with the uh
promulgation of the federal or the
presidential executive order a lot of
people asked where bia felt on that
and and the reality is we have some
concerns about that also because that's
uh
forcing uh something on employers from
from the other direction
um
we're awaiting as as most employers in
the state are for the
rules the draft interim rules to be
promulgated by osha
but we fully intend to comment on them
and i'll give you an example what we've
heard from some of our members
with
more than 100 employees they they don't
understand why they're being singled out
and they don't understand why employers
of 90 people
aren't aren't those employees in the
workplace at the same risk so
there's concern coming from both
directions
so again if i understood that right
you're not exactly in favor of the
federal mandates that are coming down
but you believe that as an individual
employer they should be able to make a
mandate if they choose yeah we're not to
leave that flexibility our position
right now is we are not opposed to the
federal mandate but we have not
indicated that we're in favor of it
either and we will likely be uh
commenting on the osha proposed rules
during the public comment period okay a
couple follow-up questions so are you at
all concerned for your businesses given
the fact that the federal immunity
portion of of of we're going to talk
about vaccinations because that's what
we're talking about mandates and
vaccinations um that that given broad
immunity that the federal government's
given the vaccine manufacturers
that any death or injuries that result
as a as it relates to these vaccines in
your business mandate that that
liability may somehow rest on your
businesses that those businesses would
be subject to that that a employee can
sue because you chose to mandate
a vaccine and that resulted in injury
that it's your responsibility because
they can't go upstream because the
manufacturers have
the vaccine manufacturers have liability
of coverage so they're they're immuno
immunized for lack for metaphase
yeah i don't have a very good way of
responding in a knowledgeable fashion to
whether employers would be at risk for
liability i can tell you that they're
already at risk for liability
from employees or members of the public
that are in the workplace customers or
suppliers
if if those individuals get coveted 19
and they feel it was because of
something that the
employer didn't do that that should have
done and many of you know we
supported legislation last year to
create what we call a safe harbor for
employers who are doing the right thing
following cdc guidelines and federal and
state health and safety guidelines
to
ensure as safe a work for a workplace as
possible but that legislation didn't
didn't make it through
so i think employers
at risk of being held liable for things
related to covet 19.
so again if i can rephrase to make sure
i i understand shorten that answer up so
it sounds like you're saying there's
liability on both sides whether they
mandate or don't mandate there's there's
potential liability i would guess so but
you're getting that answer from a
non-lawyer with no experience in
liability litigation
so i'm going to switch over and ask
questions around um
the mandate mandates and and business
and how they relate to exemptions right
so
um
the question i i
asked yesterday and i'll ask again today
is around when i'm gonna use religious
exemptions first because they're the
easiest to understand um recently the um
surgeon generals come out and said that
they think the religious exemptions are
being abused and you should be
investigated further which put pressure
on businesses to either investigate more
or to outright deny them because it's
just you know they don't want to undergo
that so i guess my question is is
appropriate for business to be in the
place of having decide whether a
person's religious enough to be entitled
to an exemption or would it be better if
somehow we clean that up to make it so
your statute your businesses would have
something to fall back on for granting a
religious exemption i um
the religious exemption may be the most
easily understood but it's probably the
most difficult for an employer to to
deal with um
a medical exemption is pretty pretty cut
and dried if you are able to provide uh
some documentation from from a physician
indicating that there is a medical
reason why you shouldn't have to receive
a vaccination that's pretty black and
white
a religious exemption is obviously a lot
greater and it does concern a lot of
employers
and i don't i suspect how employers
from employer to employer
action from from new hampshire's
uh commission on civil rights if the
employee feels that they're being
discriminated against because of their
our religion they can
file a claim with with the commission
and that's a risk that employers are
cognizant of
and i don't i i don't
i can't say how employers are going to
respond to that particular exemption
other than it's one that is generally
acknowledged as being
something that employers would certainly
consider
in terms of providing an exemption
and so go going to the medical again i
i'm thinking that again the same thing
is it would it be easier for employers
um or or is it
tough for employers because you have to
open up a medical chart and give here's
the reasons why and then make a
determination whether that my natural
path as compared to my regular m general
practitioner who signed one how does
that interplay and is that a real doctor
not a real doctor is it a you know
you know who signed it was it you know
so putting the industry in that position
of making those determinations is that
again is that something the industry
wants or would it be better to have some
sort of clarity around that i i don't
know if it's something industry wants i
think it's just an acknowledgement there
are going to be reasons
reasonable reasons why an individual may
feel that they should be exempted
from
having to to
receive a vaccine and employers
understand that how that plays out i
don't really know at this point and like
i said it may
differ from employer to employer
but i think we i think again if
in the conversation
we agree that there's some liability
attached there
uh correct that again in the case of a
religious exemption right that's denied
right there's a civil rights action that
could potentially be brought forward um
and and so
clarity proud that probably a good idea
i i
would agree that clarity is probably a
good idea i'm not willing to sign on to
anything just because it makes it
clearer understood
thank you dave
erica go ahead oh thank you if i can
actually circle back to those limited
liability bills um i we had heard one of
those in education where i sat last year
my question to you i know you're not a
lawyer
but uh following the guidelines put out
by the cdc um would would have protected
the employers from any liability in the
bill as initially introduced would
i'm sorry i wanted to let you finish
okay sorry i thought you were saying um
so it would have protected any employers
from liability if they followed cdc
guidelines and the cdc guidelines are
for vaccination is would that have
essentially placed a mandate on
employers
through in order to avoid that liability
risk
um
are you
asking if the cdc had
a vaccine mandate because they don't
no not a mandate but the way that the
limited liability bill was written it
said that employers who are following
the guidelines put set forth by the cdc
will be
will not have liability and
yes
the cdc and others other federal or
state health and safety guidelines
except in cases of gross negligence if
there was an employer that was just
ignoring
everything and saying the heck with it
subject to potential litigation relating
to that
so it was only for gross negligence not
for businesses who weren't following the
guidelines the
no the exact opposite i think if i
understood you the the safe harbor
was for those employers who were making
good faith efforts to follow
federal and state guidelines it would
not have provided a safe harbor for
employers
who were just grossly negligent and
chose not to even make a good faith
effort to comply
right so i'd like your opinion on what a
good faith effort is to have employees
vaccinated when the cdc guidelines are
to vaccinate
everybody
would it be a good faith effort where
you just ask your employees to be
vaccinated or would you need to take
further steps in order to have that
well the shield of liability doesn't
exist so
um you know
it's actually retained there are
retained bills so it may come through
perhaps
um
i think
my understanding of the cdc guidelines
is that they recognize
and recommend that vaccinations are the
best method for
avoiding or preventing the spread of
coven 19.
and so i would think that employers who
choose to
may choose to have a vaccine
mandate there's no requirement other
than the
presidential executive employer a
presidential executive order on
employers of 100 or more or those with
federal contracts to implement a vaccine
mandate so i i'm
not sure i see
a correlation between whether employers
choose to have a mandate or not as
acting in a good faith effort um it
sounded like you just said that having a
mandate would be a shield if those if
those laws that were those uh bills that
are retained went into action
do you belie do you believe that having
a mandate would protect them from that
liability if these laws pass
i believe it is something that they
could use to demonstrate that they're
making a good faith effort
i think they could
use if they're conducting education
programs about the efficacy of vaccines
that's something that could be used to
demonstrate a good faith effort if
not do things that are commonly
recognized as trying to spread to reduce
the spread of kova 19 like
cleaning surface areas you know
requiring employees to to wash their
hands after using the restroom just
common
common things that that are in place
then
then i think they would be in danger of
being found grossly negligent
i guess anybody else have anything else
i had a question i lost it so
well you know where to find me yeah i'll
come out and talk to you david if i
can't remember if i remember it um any
anybody else have a question
there being none david thank you very
much for your testimony oh actually i
remember david is there any place in uh
so one of the two areas we're looking at
is again
where law
intersects
in medical intervention with citizenry
right with our citizens right and so
including immunizations and so the other
area we're talking about is regulations
right so agency regulations are you
aware of any
agency regulations that impact your
membership
that require either a shall or shall not
i know yesterday we heard some testimony
around
the federal motor carrier law right so
we understand that there's some drug
testing and things that have to happen
there and we recognize that aspect of
agency rules but is there any place else
you can think of where there might be
some agency rules or some laws that
impact and say
businesses must do have their employees
do this and relative to medical
intervention so again like i said in the
case of vaccines you're sticking a
needle in someone's arm right so you're
requiring something in the case of a
drug test you're withdrawing and testing
a specimen so um
so that is there any other place you can
think of where in your industry there's
laws or agency regulations that come
back to have this intervention with with
your workers and the citizenry yeah off
off the top of my head i don't know that
i can respond to that if if you would
like i'm happy we have
as you can imagine a number of companies
with very savvy hr people and attorneys
who
are employment law attorneys and i'd be
happy to to query them
and then respond back to you via email
it's just off the top of my head i don't
that'd be great because that's exactly
what we're looking for is where again in
law agency rules we have that
intersection and if it's impacting any
of your businesses and their workers we
appreciate that information i'll i'll do
that and i'll follow up via email with
who's up next erica next we have curtis
berry from the new hampshire retail
association
just because i know curtis raise your
good morning again and thank you for the
invitation um i'm curtis barry and
i represent among others the new
hampshire retail association and on
their behalf i'm here today
the new hampshire retail association as
many of you have heard in years before
represents retailers from uh very small
main street shops to many of the
nationally based chains
across the country so it's all shapes
and sizes of retailers
i can start by saying just synopsizing
our the position of the new hampshire
retail association
mirrors uh any is virtually identical to
what you just heard from the business
and industry association and we
testified to that on one of the
amendments that had a public hearing in
executive departments and administration
committee last year
business owners
managers are responsible for the health
and safety of their workplace to cover
both employees and their customers and
we think it's best to leave them
with the decision-making on what's right
for that individual business in an
individual location
um
but the discussion just now i actually i
should say also mr chair that the answer
to your first two clarifying questions
on behalf of the retail association are
yes and yes
um
on the liability end
we're aware of some companies that have
made the decision to mandate uh among
our members they tend to be the larger
fortune 500 size companies um
from my perspective non-legal
perspective i would
uh
think that they rely on their legal
resources in-house to make sure that
they're covered in in respect to that um
but the discussion did touch on the
federal mandate uh mr chair and if it's
okay with you that's the bulk of my
comments okay great
um so to set the stage for a year and a
half uh like other industries
particularly the customer or the public
facing industries the retail industry
has spent
nationwide literally tens of billions of
dollars
in efforts to mitigate the spread of the
virus
masks for employees
plexiglas shields reduced customer
traffic through distancing
um limitations on the the presence
inside the store and things like that
um
the retail industry
itself represented by two major trade
associations nationally have spent
extensive resources discussing with
folks like cdc
osha national institutes
how to mitigate the spread of the virus
and pass it along to members
members individually have done the same
with
their local health local and state
health officials to seek advice
um so there are enormous resources in
the last 18 months have gone into this
we're not aware yet
of an explanation of why those efforts
have not and are not
enough
to stop the spread of the virus and why
the the current regulations from
uh osha
uh have some specifications you know how
to develop rules
you they use the word necessary
they use the term grave danger in order
to
get back to my page here sorry
um
and it's unclear why
those two uh qualifications fit the
current situation for example on the day
that the president announced the current
mandate that seven day average of new
cases was over 147 000 nationwide per
day
as of october 1st
that average had dropped to 90 000 per
day
and as of yesterday the seven day moving
average was
uh under 65 000 new cases per day it's a
decline of 55 percent since the
president announced the the requirement
we haven't heard an explanation yet
why the mandate is still at this point
necessary
as mentioned in the previous discussion
retailers like every other business is
struggling for employees
employees that are working
are
stretched in many cases
they're stretched
they're resentful
and yet the mandate doesn't seem to
consider the impact on employee
retention
and recruitment
as i mentioned some members have taken
it upon themselves to implement a
mandate on their own
but they feel that that is in the best
interest of their business and they've
made it after an assessment of their
next is
um
uh mixed messaging i think what we've
heard most from
from our members
um it started in may the cdc released
released guidance um saying that fully
this is a quote fully vaccinated people
no longer need need to wear a mask or
physically distance in any setting
on june 10th osha then issued what it
called a tailored standard aimed at the
workers uh of in most danger
but what we've heard is this new mandate
adds even more contradiction to the
mixed messaging that we've already heard
um
another inconsistency mr gervais already
mentioned we're puzzled by employees of
a hundred or more employees
in that setting are in grave danger
again according to the osha standards
and employees
of businesses that employ 99 or fewer
we're faced with a lot of lack of
guidance i guess you would say
as at this point
retailers don't know how to
differentiate yet between vaccinated and
unvaccinated
we also need to keep in mind that
we are uncertain how other federal
regulations and statutes apply
hipaa
ada uh chief among those and there are
others
um we don't know how and where to
document the vaccine status of employees
we don't know how to process requests
for exemptions
the president stated that workers would
need the unvaccinated workers would need
to show a negative test at least once a
week
i did some real quick
back of the envelope i guess you would
call it
analysis
i could be wrong but
this could impose a mandate of a hundred
thousand tests in the state of new
hampshire among all employees
per week
and we're not sure who covers the cost
it's an unfunded mandate obviously if
the government's not covering the cost
if the government's going to mandate
this
are we allowed to pass that cost on to
employees we're not sure
um
i think um
one last point to sum up and then i got
we have one other area i'd like to cover
um
we're very wary and would extend a word
of caution to make sure that mandates or
prohibitions
at the state level do not conflict with
what's imposed at the federal level that
imposes a great deal of difficulty in
all businesses i'm sure
the second area i'd like to cover very
briefly mr chair is
uh the mask mandates that we saw
in the past
and this is something we had both as an
association and individual members had
extensive discussions with law
enforcement both at the state level and
in individual municipalities here in new
hampshire
which is the requirement that customers
entering a retail location
wear a mask
all of those officials
i'm happy to say understood our position
and agreed um
but what our request was at the time and
i use this as an example for for other
mandates
the request was at the time that any
mandate should not require enforcement
by the retail employee
retail employees like law enforcement
are are not trained in
detention are not trained in conflict
resolution or any of the other things
that
local police or other law enforcement
are
and to require uh retail employees to
enforce those type of mandates is unfair
to both the the store and that employee
putting them in that in that situation
again thankfully um everyone agreed we
had great conversations in fact there
was a
um after the the state's mandate a
opinion or a document that came out from
the attorney general's office that in
essence said as much so we were thankful
for that um i'm happy to answer
questions to the best of my ability
great thank you so i just in just the
issue of transparency curtis and i
served on the governor's reopening task
force together and we wrote most of the
guidance
for the retail industry and opening in
plexiglasses and masking and distancing
and how much material could be on the
shelf for how long and that kind of
stuff so just so everyone's aware that
kirsten i did serve on that committee
together and worked through this during
the early phases of this pandemic
um questions anybody from the committee
so curtis i'm going to ask you the same
kind of questions i think you answered
them with a yes and yes but i want to
make sure i'm clear
so again we talk about things like
religious exemptions for mandates right
so
you would prefer the
st legislature not
let's at least help clarify that issue
and that we don't want businesses making
determinations whether or not a person
is religious enough to be entitled to uh
um we don't want the businesses to have
to go into that model of determining if
they're religious enough to to warrant
and and be entitled to a a religious
exemption now it's my turn to ask a
clarifying question are you speaking in
terms of the case where there's a state
mandate
so i'm speaking again so in certain
instances we have you have the osha rule
coming down so you have some of your
businesses may be subject to that osha
rule
you're going to have other instances we
have smaller
businesses that may be federal
contractors that'll be subject to the
executive order so
again relative to those businesses that
do have to now force a mandate coming
down from the federal government whether
the business wants it or not the
business is kind of stuck in this now
decision of of how do i deal with my
employees in a time when trying to find
an employee is next to impossible um and
and keep keep my workforce at the same
time be responsive to my employees so
questions on the religious exemption
side um would it be helpful to the to
the businesses to have some sort of
clarification on that from the state so
that you know you're not stuck in this
civil rights liability hole
um
the religious exemption specifically is
not something that's come up in our
outreach to members
you know after the invitation or
otherwise um but generally my sense
would be yes because as i mentioned on
several other pieces there's a lack of
clarity how do we record it how do we
verify it that sort of thing i guess i
would question how the state
could help clarify a federal
regulation that that part of marshall
okay
um
and then the same issue
so you in your workforce on on these
mandates coming down is it do you have
the same we heard from dave from the bia
that you know some employees have staged
a day off work off work walk off because
they don't want to have the mandates and
it impacts that have you seen that in
your industry as well no um to my
knowledge by and large employers haven't
at least our members haven't imposed
mandates
those that have uh have reported that
they haven't had pushback or any
problems
thank you thank you
anything else
not hearing any
anybody else on the business side are we
so is there anybody else in the business
industry that wanted to speak and didn't
put in a pink card we're going to
otherwise we're going to move over to
the healthcare field
and talk to them
all right then who's up erica for the
healthcare field um i'm not so good at
reading the handwriting i believe it's
steve a hearn
from the new hampshire hospital
association
i apologize if i got that wrong no
that's perfectly fine it's onon
how do i spell that a-h-n-e-n
thank you
i'll get to know that soon well my
mother always told me my handwriting
would
be a problem
so good morning
my mr chairman members of the committee
my name is steve and i'm the president
of new hampshire hospital association
i'm here representing all 26 of our
state's community hospitals as well as
all of our specialty hospitals
hospitals and their healthcare heroes
have been on the front lines of the
pandemic for the past year and a half
and they are as stressed and challenged
today as they have been at any point
during the pandemic
you know during those first early days
of the pandemic we all watched with
horror as we saw hospitals overseas
literally being overwhelmed
with covet 19 patients and you know
one of the overriding goals has always
been to ensure that we had the hospital
bed capacity to care for those patients
you know the response was swift
in addition to lockdown stay at home
orders and more hospitals across the
country and here in new hampshire
canceled all non-urgent elective
procedures to preserve the personal
protective equipment which was in short
supply at the time and bed capacity to
ensure they could serve patients with
covet 19 and in addition much of the
health care system outside of hospitals
moved to virtual models of care to keep
people safe and socially distant
i could not be prouder of our hospitals
and the teams of dedicated doctors
nurses other clinicians environmental
food services and all the other staff
who worked tirelessly over the past 18
plus months to ensure that every patient
could get the high quality care that
they need
in december of last year new hampshire
like the rest of the country was
experiencing one of the worst surges of
the pandemic
it was then that several several nurses
from the elliott hospital in manchester
were among the first caregivers in the
state to receive the covet 19 vaccine
that day was one of the brightest spots
in what had been a very long and dark
period of the pandemic as it brought
hope that we finally had a safe and
effective tool to combat the virus and
eventually return to normal what we all
want getting back to work to school
traveling visiting with friends going
out to a movie and so much more
as vaccination rates increased in new
hampshire we witnessed an expected and
welcome reduction in the number of new
cases hospitalizations and deaths
on january 1st of this year new
hampshire hospitals hit their highest
peak of coven 19 hospitalizations of 334
patients
on july 1st that number had dropped to
just 17 patients
unfortunately as the more contagious
delta variant has taken root in new
hampshire that number was 190 on monday
of this week november 1st
the vast majority of those patients that
are hospitalized are unfortunately
unvaccinated while we are seeing more
breakthrough cases in new hampshire
across the country we know that the most
effective means of preventing
hospitalizations of coba 19 patients is
to receive one of the vaccines approved
for use in the u.s
in august the new hampshire hospital
association and its member hospitals
announced a consensus statement in
support of requiring our healthcare
workforce to be vaccinated against cova
19 in order to protect the health and
safety of our patients our staff and the
community
hospitals would announce and develop
their individual policies over the
ensuing weeks and months and
implementing those requirements
hospitals engaged in robust education
with their staff about the benefits of
the vaccine and would comply with all
relevant and state federal and
guidelines including offering medical
and religious exemptions
hospitals have an inherent
responsibility to protect the health and
safety of their patients who by their
very nature are very ill and cope and
the cobalt 19 vaccine is the most
effective way we can do that the science
and data overwhelmingly demonstrate that
the vaccines are safe and effective
reduce reduce transmission and prevent
serious illness
hospitalization and death all of the
vaccines authorized for use went through
rigorous studies and review by the
federal agencies before their approval
for emergency use and one of those
vaccines has already been fully approved
for use by the federal food and drug
administration
requiring vaccinations of our staff from
communicable diseases is not new for
hospitals in new hampshire hospitals
have required vaccination against the
flu for instance for many years with the
same type of exemptions allowed for
relative to the kova 19 vaccines
we believe this is absolutely the right
thing to do
to protect the health and safety of our
patients our staff and the community the
vast majority of hospital staff have
been vaccinated we've heard many from
many who support the vaccine requirement
to protect their health and that of
their patients
but let me come back to where i started
this conversation hospital bed capacity
hospitals have seen a significant
increase in patient volumes over the
past several months from patients who do
not have covid19 but who have other
serious illnesses that require
hospitalizations
many patients went without care during
the pandemic or skipped routine
screenings or evaluations and their
conditions are now much more serious
add to that a surge in cobot 19
hospitalizations a workforce shortage
that existed before the pandemic and has
only been exacerbated because of it and
the challenges that hospitals are
already experiencing when trying to find
a bed especially in intensive care unit
bed here in new hampshire or across the
region and you can understand the true
impact of this pandemic on the health
care system
as i have said i am incredibly proud of
the tremendous work our hospitals and
their health care heroes are doing
every day to ensure that these patients
that their patients are able to get the
care they need but if we aren't able to
turn the corner on this pandemic and
start trending in the right direction
with fewer new cases and
hospitalizations that job will only
become more difficult
if we're going to ensure that we have
the hospital beds available to care for
every patient regardless of whether they
are suffering from coba 19 heart attack
or the victim of an accident we have to
do everything we can now to make that
happen
thank you for the opportunity to share
our thoughts be happy to answer any
great thank you
members
erica thank you mr chair thank you for
taking the questions uh my first
question is to the number of um
vaccinated and non-vaccinated are those
numbers that are kept by the hospital
association or do we speak to the
department of public health for those
those numbers um are reported by the
hospitals uh to the the state um and are
available from the state and is there a
category for those who have been
vaccinated but haven't yet reached that
category of fully vaccinated so those
who catch it in those first two weeks
before full protection we do um
hospitals are asked to categorize those
patients who are hospitalized whether
they have been vaccinated whether
they've been fully vaccinated um or not
vaccinated at all so those those that is
captured in that in that in that respect
fantastic i'm glad those three data
points are available um let's see and
then i have another question on the
exemptions for the flu vaccines and the
copit vaccines has there been a
comparison about the approval rate for
religious and medical exemptions for the
flu vaccine compared to the cobit
vaccine um there is not um as you can
expect those um policies are being
implemented you know hospital by
hospitals so they're not all necessarily
the same and they all haven't gone into
effect so um some have you know
they they're going into effect in this
month and next month um and so we don't
know what those ultimate
percentages might look like at this time
okay so with that there's they're not
modeling the exemption protocols for the
coveted vaccine on the flu vaccine
they're trying to look at this one
differently
they're using the same methodology some
same model that they will be using i
just don't have a sense yet as to you
know how many are being uh granted and
and how many are not those that's just
something we don't we don't have thank
you i'm sorry i'm getting into those i'm
an economist i love data
erica can i move on to senator
welcome back senator
you have a couple more questions if you
can
wrap it up
actually i'm good to wrap up thank you
thank you senator go ahead so there's a
microphone over there so people online
good morning steve good morning senator
um
we've had
a number of conversations over the last
couple of months about medical and
religious exemptions
i just want to say for the record i
appreciate the fact that you've been
um as willing to
as an association and some of your
individual members that we've talked to
both myself and senator morse
as you know
um
do you want to comment any further
on
you know what constitutes in some of the
members cases the
grounds for a medical exception
so
and i know that every hospital has
developed a somewhat different policy so
i just but for the record i think it
would be good for the
committee to hear
that your members are responding
to
the
medical and religious exception requests
they they are and they're reviewing
those you know on a case-by-case basis i
think
your point relative to medical
exemptions there's been a lot of um you
know questions about um
from those who are of child bearing age
um and those
the the the science and the data would
say that they are safe and effective for
for those who are in that category um
but there are those who are trying to be
flexible to ensure that you know those
individuals um you know are able to to
continue to to participate in the
workforce um and perhaps delaying their
uh you know date of of a vaccination um
and again
i can't speak and say what everyone is
doing they're doing those things on an
individual basis but they're certainly
working to try and be um
you know as flexible as they can but at
the same time ensuring the health and
safety of of their their employees and
so um
i guess just more comment at this point
i i think recognizing
the
work that you folks have done all of
your
you know 26 members and trying to keep
people safe and get the care that they
need over the last
almost two years has been exceptional i
don't think anybody could say
it is anything other than exceptional so
um
that just needs to be said steve so
thank you very much thank you
i would also
um say
i think you're between a rock and a hard
plate
um in terms of
you know
trying to keep your patients safe trying
to keep your staff safe but also
recognizing
um the fact that some people have qualms
and i think you know whether it's
myocarditis women of childbearing age
people that have already had covid
um
so i i just want to say i think that
the response by the hospital association
and your members
for that kind of flexibility on
religious and medical exceptions it's
difficult
there's no question about that it's
but i appreciate that flexibility
there's no question it it is a it is a
difficult implementation for sure um but
in terms of
our
primary responsibility and focus has to
be on the health and safety of our
patients
our staff and our community um so i
understand the challenge that it creates
um but i think
when our hospitals step forward and
remember this was before uh federal
mandates uh you know were announced
they felt it was absolutely the right
thing to do from a public health
perspective
to protect the health and safety of of
their patients
we know that those who have received the
covet 19 vaccine
are much less likely to
be infected to face serious illness and
hospitalization and and death and that
has to be our primary focus and you know
the reality is as i said we are seeing
you know an increasing number of of
covet 19 cases and
that you know the need to to increase
our vaccination rates along with all of
the other public health measures that
we've talked about
are so vitally important
to put us in the right direction we all
want to get back to normal when covet
isn't calling the shots um when we can
do what you know we want to do um
and we strongly believe that that the
vaccine is is the the path forward and
that's why our hospitals step forward to
to require that their their employees
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question and
thank you for your testimony
i just had a thought
um i know that
there are some people who
object to getting the vaccine because of
the documentation
you think that they're you know having
to give their name and their life
history and blah blah
i wonder if
there would ever be a consideration for
people to be able to
just
come in get the vaccine in a specific
place and just be
numbered
rather than have to give their name or
maybe just give their name but not
have to give all other information that
just seems
i know there are people like that out
there who just don't want
to be documented they feel that's above
and beyond their
privacy because it's more open than
your record with your doctor or
something like that and was that ever
given any consideration at all
just an open clinic to go you know i
don't know i don't remember back
when i was in school when they had the
mass
inoculations for polio and stuff like
that if we had to
give our names or
i don't remember that my new detail
probably in fifth grade or something
like that i assume you're referring to
the the vaccine registry right um you
know that is something new hampshire's
the last state in the country to enact
a vaccine registry it's an important
public health tool um you know making
certain that we can
track that vaccine and that dose and
that lot so in case there were any
issues and those those types of things i
absolutely believe that that vaccine
registry needs to be um you know
protected um so that that data is
protected um but i have but i do believe
that that it is important and a helpful
public health tool one that um can help
us in in in the fight against covet 19
but i i absolutely do believe that we
need to ensure that that data is is kept
uh private um because it should be yeah
thank you i have one more mr ad
representative
people who have had covet
and even those who have been
hospitalized by being one um
had a blood i had a blood test and said
that i have the i still have the
antibodies
is there any
consideration that's given to
uh i think you kind of
mentioned that in in in one of your
statements toward the end of your
presentation
that um there's
there's no distinction
if if you're hesit like if you're
hesitant to get the vaccine after you
have
um have had covert
because there are conflicting
reports of how
uh that could affect your your immune
system or whether it's good for you or
whatever
is there any consideration given to
people who have had
covet or do you know like when they go
to a nursing home or something like that
are there any
are those personal
um
uh personal decisions that are made
through the individual
nursing homes or are these mandates uh
that you have to wear face shield you
have to wear this because you don't have
the vaccine but even though you've had
it it doesn't matter that you have the
antibodies is that some decision that
that is made
locally uh or is that something that's
comes from
the state agencies well number one i'm
glad to see you here um
you've obviously uh recommended it it
was a long haul um so i'm glad that
you're you're well um you know we've
certainly
we're learning a lot um about covet as
we go through this um a recent study
of 7 000 hospitalized patients who had
covet 19 who who had coped 19 and
therefore um had the antibodies um were
still significantly you know more likely
to you know be reinfected with copa 19
um and that's why you know it has been
and continues to be a recommendation for
those that have had cover 19 to also get
the vaccine um as it provides even
further um you know immunity against
covet 19. um as it as relates to who
makes that determination um i believe
the
the instruction or the direction um that
is coming from you know public health
agencies you know whether it's federal
state or or or local has been um that
that is not um sufficient um to you know
demonstrate um you know immunity against
the the
against copa 19 and and uh would
therefore if there was a mandate um that
it would be required that that that you
get that um even though you've had cobia
19 before
would it be possible to get that study
from you your email later thank you
anything
so i i have a couple questions
so
um
we're going to start with them with with
breakthrough cases and the and and
what's happening there and relative to
the hospital's response to those and
inflict and and imposing a mandate
um
so given that we know that breakthrough
cases happen right we know that
my understanding is roughly one in ten
of the hospitalizations currently are
at a minimum one in ten are
breakthrough cases that are at the
hospitals
[Applause]
given that we know that
a vaccine mandate on employees as
compared to testing right again if your
goal is to
make sure that your patients are safe
and your workforce can show up for work
um
isn't testing for infection status given
that we know that vax people who are
vaccinated could still be infectious
still shed the disease the virus and
still infect other people
wouldn't infection status testing be
more accurate in order to protect and be
be
you know be more absolute in achieving
your goal of patient safety rather than
vaccine status
it's certainly an important component of
cover 19 mitigation
but it's not an absolute
because you know as we have certainly
come to know that someone can
be
asymptomatic and yet continue to shed
that virus
and even can be tested um and may not
uh you know
produce enough uh for the test to show
that they are coveted positive um and
therefore i i would say that that's not
an absolute that that we would um
suggest is is
would would be uh
a replacement uh for a vaccine
requirement
again we we know that
those who are vaccinated are less much
less likely to you know become infected
to have serious illness
but currently you don't do any testing
is that right that that the testing that
is done is only at a at an employee's
request that that again we know that
breakthrough cases have we know we have
hospitalizations on those and and we
have no idea whether or not an employee
is currently walking the hospital is
infected or not right because we don't
do any testing we know they've got the
virus because you've a virus the
vaccination but we don't know what their
infection status is so the protection to
the public is what
well we
we know that if they are vax if they are
fully vaccinated they are much less
likely to become infected and to shed
the virus um and to the extent that
there's testing that goes on um it
revolves around for for vaccinated
employees um would be uh you know if
they are experiencing symptoms or if
they have had a close contact actually
um the
the guidance um does not suggest that um
if you've been a close contact that you
were required to be tested it is not not
a not a bad thing to do
and some
institutions may may be doing that
themselves
but the the current guidelines suggest
that if you were fully vaccinated you
have the highest protection in addition
to all of the other things that that we
do in the hospital um in terms of you
know personal protective equipment air
flow and all of the other
infection prevention mitigation efforts
and i very much appreciate that i i
guess my question goes back to what you
were just talking about was that the
fact that we know that if you get
vaccinated your symptoms are more likely
less so you're less
we know that's not going to cause
hospitalization your symptoms way less
the person may be less likely to
understand if they're even infected
and we're not testing them and we know
breakthrough cases happen so
how how does that protect the model how
is that a protective model versus
testing on a regular basis
there's no
whether it's
a testing protocol whether it's a
vaccine protocol whether it's a face
mask whether it's hand washing whether
it's sanitization there there is no
method that is 100 percent effective
they all
sort of they get layered together and
the most effective means of preventing
infection hospitalization and death
remains the copa 19 one of the three
code 19 vaccines okay
um follow-up question is relative to we
know that again the covid vaccine is i'm
going to stick to that because it's a
topic we're on right now but the um the
covid vaccine is not curative in nature
it's mitigating in nature right and we
know that over time it's been it's been
shown that the protection wanes and we
need booster shots
so is it is it the hospital's intent or
or or follow-up to mandate this vaccine
for a lifetime and all the boosters that
follow so we're doing a lifetime of
injections on on all workers
um
to be considered fully vaccinated
remains you know having either one of
the two dosed uh
models or the the one dose j and j um i
do not know um and
i i we have not um you know spoken or
asked the the question of the hospitals
whether whether or not the booster um
will be included as part of that mandate
i think we're
i mean those boosters were just uh
approved um here recently so that's a
question that i don't know the answer to
that but as i understand it um
full immunity continues to be defined as
uh the the two dose uh you know pfizer
or moderna and the one dose jnj
so
again to follow up with that so but we
know that i think
healthcare workers were in the first
wave of and so that was may of last year
i think it was
for roosters yeah no for just the
vaccine right
started back in december of of 2020
december of 2020
and again if i follow studies right and
you can obviously correct me if my wrong
i think that i think the studies have
shown that after three months the
vaccine starts to wane after six months
it's really whether whether or not it's
effective or not so all right i don't
think the question is whether it's
effective or not after six months but it
is recommended that at six months the
vaccine immunity has begun to to wane
and therefore uh ensure that for those
that are immunocompromised who are more
susceptible to covet 19 those that work
in high risk occupations like health
care
should consider getting the the the
booster
okay
and then the last question i have is
relative the same same question i posed
to the um
to the business industry are you
concerned about any liability by a
forced mandate that might be pushed down
to you for immunization and and either a
death or um or injury that results as a
vaccination that was caused by a mandate
that the business would be liable of
that given that the um
the
pharmaceutical industry the
vaccine manufacturer have been given
broad immunity from lawsuit
as you heard from others i think you
know there's there's liability um
whether there's a vaccine requirement or
not um but i
you know
vaccine requirements are not new um i i
believe you know in my heart that they
are the right thing um and i believe
that hospitals and employers should have
the right to require that um and um
so
thank you any further questions from the
committee representative leon um thank
you um as to that study did that
evaluate both those who had been
recently immunized for covid and those
with the natural immunity
so
the
i'm not sure what how to define recently
um since we're only dealing with people
who've been able to be vaccinated within
the last
less than 12 months so um i think so i
think the answer is yes okay um because
um i i
have there's some scientific question as
to the as for the sample size in that
study and also i do know that some of
the statements that have been made have
referenced blog articles and that sort
of level of evidence as we get more
information will the new hampshire
hospital association look to those a and
b quality of evidence as we're able to
develop more clinical experience we
always will be looking at the the
clinical evidence and the clinical
experience
to help guide our decision making and
that's what our hospitals are doing um
and so we will continue to to evaluate
all of that we believe that the the data
and the the science has been
overwhelming uh in favor of the vaccines
but we will continue to look at all of
that um and make any
adjustments as necessary
in my last follow-up outside of an
emerging situation such as this a lot of
these levels of evidence would be
classified as level c or d because
observational studies and other
methodological problems
i know that we're limited in what we
know but i just want assurance that as
the standard of evidence increases it
will be more discriminating as to which
which science we follow and which ones
we've done more research and and realize
the way that uh science has moved
we will continue to use evidence-based
uh protocols to uh to adopt policies and
procedures and protocols um to ensure
the health and safety of our workforce i
can assure you that thank you
representative shaw yes just a quick
comment um
i have to tell you that
in my 11 days in the hospital
the elliott hospital
care that i received was
absolutely superior i
i it's always been my hospital to go to
for testing and stuff had three children
uh there but
that i never had
any type of surgery or long-term care
and uh
i was just amazed at the um at the care
and uh the uh you know it was
i was very pleased and i uh i think that
the decision of your
um uh hospital associations
to have a group
like a group it was like a unit
for um
for covet in it we had they had
in-service doctors this new thing about
a unit of doctors for the hospital um it
is an amazing thing and it took them 79
years to get me in there but i only
stayed 11.
but well i'm so i'm so glad you had a
positive experience and i really did
i see you
intensive care unit
yeah thank you no thank you and and i i
just want to sort of build on that
comment
you know we talk a lot about the
important role that that hospitals play
in their community every day
they stand ready to care
for anyone and everyone regardless of
who they are what's happened to them
what's in their wallet um or where
they're from and you know the the blue
and white h that we see in our
communities you know stands for the
mission and commitment that our
hospitals and their caregivers make
every single day they come into work uh
to care for others to help improve
health uh to relieve suffering and and
that they do it with such great care and
compassion but i must say they're
they're getting tired um they've been in
this sprint for the last 18 19 months
and you know they want to get back to
normal they want to be able to say to
any hospital to any patient please we'd
love to to serve you we'd love to take
that transfer um you know we'd love to
be able to to care for for those
patients and that job is getting so much
more challenging as we deal with the
rise in in in hospitalizations not just
covet but non-coven and all of the rest
um and so as i said you know earlier you
know those caregivers are the backbone
of of what we do and and they took great
care of you and i'm so pleased to hear
that um but uh
we we owe our hospitals a dedica of debt
of gratitude uh for the work that
they've done and continue to do and
we'll continue
just one real quick follow-up
i my one of the most impressive things
that i saw in the hospitals was the fact
that
uh i had two two roommates that came and
went that were uh did not speak english
and they are able to use a laptop
to connect with an interpreter
that talks to
that patient in their language
and makes them understand and relaxes
them and
lets them know what's going on
and they were both totally
non-nonverbal in english and i found
that to be absolutely amazing and
wonderful
thank you and and i think jeff go ahead
thank mr chair and thank you for being
here um i also have i have a daughter
who's an icu nurse and has dealt with
many covert patients so yes they do get
tired and they do get wary thank you
um i brought up
earlier about
to go with vaccination and possible
boosters and they may continue on as
the efficacy wanes
boosters may be necessary and continue
on or as another variant may become
available
um
and then
those vaccines would be required for
your employees to protect both the
employees and the patients
wouldn't that be similar to the same
thing as
your employees being required yearly
to get a flu vaccine
in a similarity yes
thank you jeff anything else so again i
think i speak to the entire committee
when i say that obviously we we very
much appreciate our frontline workers
and we understand the stress and strain
i i have to pull up as you were talking
about hospital utilization
from the hhs.gov website the hospital
utilization and
for for the committee's just knowledge
is that according to this out of the
3021 beds that we have available in new
hampshire on 30 hospitals reporting
approximately 6.52 percent are in use by
covid patients
the balance are for other patients that
are not covid related so less than 10
percent nearly 5 percent are
actually covered patients
and how that's impacting our hospitals
um i i did have one you made a comment i
made a note to ask you about it so we
talked about a little bit about the
registry
um
and i i just i had a secondary question
because you were talking about how
important it was and i'm like isn't it i
thought it was true because i used to
work in healthcare i t and install
electronic medical record systems and
isn't it true that a doctor has an
obligation to record any patient
procedure or contact within their within
their record keeping system whatever
that is including their electronic
medical record system so the registry
isn't the sole
you know place this resides that each
provider already keeps these records or
are obligated to keep the records
actually um and that's as a secondary
component
that's correct although as you know the
current registry does allow for patients
to opt out
of the registry so they can keep that
information from the registry um you
know the the doctor would certainly want
to have that information in their
medical records so that they had a
complete history
of that patient's health and and health
care
thank you i just want to make sure i was
clear that that was in fact that the
doctor keeps the record and the
secondary record is the registry that
the primary record is the doctor's emr
who actually performed the procedure
anything else
nope
next up erica thank you very much
appreciate it again uh you know we very
much appreciate all the first
first line workers in the hospitals and
all that they do thank you
next up we have mike padmore and dr
kristen johnston from the new hampshire
[Music]
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
mike padmore uh i'm the director of
advocacy for the new hampshire medical
society uh representing physicians
across new hampshire um could you speak
a little bit better into the mic so
is the red light on in front of you uh
it is yes
um and i just want to thank the
committee for inviting us to testify
this morning um i know that we've had uh
uh at least one uh of our healthcare
stakeholders testify today and i think
we do plan to have some others uh so
what we really wanted to focus on was uh
the pediatric uh community uh so i have
with me today dr kristen johnson uh a
practicing pediatrician from the
seacoast uh and with that i'll turn it
over to her and then i'm certainly uh
happy to answer questions after uh after
thank you
good morning my name is dr kristen
calcane johnson i'm a resident of
newfields new hampshire i'm a practicing
pediatrician in exeter new hampshire and
i'm a frontline worker
i took time out of my practice uh in
exeter today to be here
because this is a very important issue
for me
as a pediatrician as a parent of two
children
in the new hampshire public schools and
as the spouse of a teacher in our new
hampshire public schools as well
i'm here in support of ongoing
requirements for medical interventions
for attending schools in new hampshire
particularly immunizations as this seems
to be a primary focus of this bill
to start i wanted to do a quick review
process on the process for vaccines
recommended for children in general
once a vaccine for an infectious agent
has been developed the vaccine goes
through four phases of trials looking at
both safety and efficacy
if it is shown to be safe and effective
it will go to the fda the food and drug
administration
for approval and licensing
after that process uh we've started to
see this on the news regularly that goes
to the centers for disease control and
their advisory committee on immunization
practices the acip
that committee specifically looks at
that data and makes recommendations for
who is most at risk in this population
what's the dose what's the timing
who should and should not get this
vaccine
and then the head of the cdc ultimately
weighs in on that there are committees
within the american academy of
pediatrics and the american academy of
family practice who also review this
data and make recommendations on the
vaccine scheduling as well and it's the
consensus of these three groups of
experts that creates the recommended
vaccine schedule
this is regularly reviewed and updated
with new vaccines covid19 being one hpv
being available in the last 20 years a
modified vaccines diphtheria tetanus and
pertussis becoming a cellular
polio vaccine going from an oral to an
injectable form and then changes for
risk for populations hepatitis a for
example
in my career has changed the indication
and the timing for patients
and it's based on this expert-led
vaccine schedule that school
requirements have been made
now understanding uh vaccines their
origin and their guideline i want to
consider the environment of our public
school settings our schools are open to
everyone in our state
we meet the needs of our most vulnerable
patients
with services originating at their
schools the federal guidelines say that
starting at age three
those medically vulnerable children get
their physical therapy their
occupational therapy their speech
therapy through our public school
systems they may learn to eat speak and
walk in our elementary schools
the
education in our united states and in
new hampshire is compulsory
there is no exemption based on who sits
next to you in class
your potential earning power your
expected lifespan the complexity of your
health needs
you must attend school and for this
reason your school needs to be a safe
place for all who do not choose to seek
their education elsewhere
there are basic requirements of
participating in our public schools just
as there are for other parts of our
community where choice is not optional
as an analogy i'd like to pause and
think about our roads
we have certain rules expectations and
enforceable laws that reduce the risk on
our state's roads one must have breaks
you can choose your mechanic you can get
another opinion or more
you can do your own brake job if you
know how no matter you must have your
car inspected annually
and or your car will be impounded
you must have brakes a steering wheel
windshield safe tires
this is for your safety and for the
safety of those around you do you need
to have a car on brakes no you can ride
a bike you can walk or some buggy
but you have to have brakes if you drive
a car you also cannot choose not to have
the school bus have a brake job and you
cannot as a taxpayer expect that you
will do the brake job on the buses to
save taxpayer money in addition while
we're talking about brakes we know that
brakes don't prevent all accidents but
having functioning breaks reduces the
likelihood of serious accidents
using this analogy and the information
on the rigorous evaluation of vaccines
and their recommended schedule we'll get
back to the subject of school vaccines
and requirements like brakes on the car
driving next to me on 101 on my way here
today i expect that the students sitting
in my son's class this morning with a
student undergoing treatment for cancer
are protected from contracting and
passing an illness which might lead to
his earlier death
in my daughter's middle school class i
expect that the students are preparing
to babysit young children are protected
from passing whooping cough
on to their care
and that uh
they
that those infants are protected from
stopping breathing from whooping cough
and dying
i also hope that they're protected from
dying themselves from the tetanus that
they may contract while out in the
schoolyard today working on their maps
they're creating for their social
studies class and i sincerely hope that
the students in my husband's high school
classes are protected from bacterial
meningitis where you get plus around
your brain and spinal cord
or the and the possibility of passing
that to one another doing their small
group work on the bus to sporting
competition and with their first kiss
and i admit that maybe that's not true
for everybody but my kids are not going
to kiss anybody until high school
so
we've seen the failure of school
requirements across the country
with outbreaks of measles mumps
pertussis or whooping cough and more
kobe continues to teach us about the
importance of school our peers our
social emotional learning as well as the
evolving science of viruses their
treatment and prevention
it remains a delicate balance of
protecting ourselves from illness with
vaccines masks and time away from school
to recover from an illness with being an
active participant in your school
community learning the basics of our
curriculum making friends learning
independence and being active the
american academy of pediatrics through
its published book the red book actually
what it's called
uh of infectious diseases has guidelines
um
and
specifically for school health uh they
have 10 pages dedicated to school
re-entrance and infectious issues and
management at school as well as another
15 pages for out of home day daycare
this group provides clear guidance
around influenza whooping cough diarrhea
and lice
when you go home when you come back what
classroom interventions are needed as we
continue to see these clusters and
outbreaks of
infectious diseases in new hampshire we
know that staying vigilant and listening
to our trusted mechanics the infectious
disease experts of the fda cdc acip aap
aafp will do the best to keep us as safe
and well as possible in the changing
world of infections and of our
communities
and i provided here just two resources
one the reference to the red book uh
it's published every couple of years
it's routinely updated
on their website and those emails come
out to practicing physicians
specifically those who are fellows of
the american academy of pediatrics but
available to anybody online
their next version version 32 is coming
out this updated this coming year of
2022.
i also referenced the children's
hospital philadelphia website uh that's
the chop.edu backslash vaccine
it's a very uh well thought out
reference for vaccines uh they provide
the studies that they reference uh very
nicely and really i think address a
large variety of questions that come up
around vaccines
including you know why would you want to
get vaccinated who shouldn't get
vaccinated and i think it's about as
unbiased as you'll find
for a resource out there
what i didn't include there but i wanted
to just pull up on a screen here for you
is just where we are with kovid right
now uh
in new hampshire for kids um i realize
that's not the only reason we're here
today uh but i do think it's important
for us to just take a quick look and see
why
my colleagues and i are tired and
worried and why i'm here today
this is just a screenshot from this
morning on the new hampshire dashboard
this is your overall trend i know it's
kind of hard to see
of covid cases for the whole population
here in new hampshire and you can see
that while we're certainly
enduring a spike as we heard about
earlier with delta
it didn't rival where we were back in
january uh december january february of
last year but we're seeing in pediatrics
is not that what we're seeing in
pediatrics right now
is a doubling of the highest rate we've
ever seen of covid here this is
specifically kids uh zero to ten uh
these have been until yesterday uh kids
that did not qualify for vaccination and
you can see that while we were doing a
lot of interventions back here in terms
of modifications of schooling et cetera
being back in place even with those
modifications we're seeing a huge surge
and so this is really pertinent this is
why
i'm up at night this is why i got up at
three o'clock in the morning yesterday
to sign my kids up for a vaccine since
they now qualify
this is why my practice is seeing over
125 of what we usually see in our office
this is why parents are missing work
this is why kids are missing school
and this is an example of why these
other components of health care i think
are super important for our children in
the school settings so i hope that's
helpful i know this is a little out of
my comfort zone but i'm happy to try to
thank you doctor i'm going to jump in
first here so um i appreciate your
testimony i'm going to switch the
conversation up just a little bit and
not talk so much about vaccines as
talked about health care in general um
yesterday we had a conversation with the
attorney general regarding informed
consent and consent and so and we also
had uh department health and human
services here talk about informed
consent
and so it's my understanding you know
the attorney the attorney general's
you know made it clear that informed
consent has to be free and voluntary
right and that and that kind of the
definition of consent right free and
voluntary
um and so my my concern is is around the
free and voluntary nature of informed
consent relative to the vaccine and so
i'm going to pose a hypothetical to you
and ask a question
and and see if i can see if we can put
this in terms that everybody can
understand
so
if a woman walked into the doctor's
office and asked for an abortion
and when the doctor through his
conversation found out the reason a
woman wanted the abortion is because the
husband said that he was going to
divorce her if she didn't get an
abortion
under informed consent and general
medical practitioner would you would a
doctor be ethically correct in giving
that abortion if that was the only
reason the woman wanted the abortion she
wanted the child but her husband was
going to divorce her take her home take
her house you know all those fears and
threats that go along with that
and that's why she wanted the abortion
not because she actually wanted the
abortion would the doctor be ethically
correct in performing the abortion
so that's a really challenging question
for me to answer because it's not one
that i've particularly had to go through
as a pediatrician who does not provide
abortions
the consent that i do in my office
for patients under 18 and balls ascent
from the patient as well as informed
consent from the parent
and then certainly for patients over 18
they are able to do their own consenting
as well
but in terms of having those complicated
conversations around abortion that is
not something that i have spent a lot of
time thinking about uh in my active
practice because of the pediatrician
that's not part of my purview
well again i'm not really talking about
the abortion talking about the decision
right to act right so again we're
talking about the physician making an
ethical decision on is should i go ahead
with this procedure or should i not
um and the question is involving
informed consent is that a voluntary
free informed consent to do the
procedure when there's a coercion on the
back end right there's a there's a
threat of divorce and the threat it's
not necessarily what the patient wants
but it's what the what the husband wants
in this case now as you can see where
i'm going with this all right we're
talking about vaccinations right so
there's a mandate and a federal mandate
out there
um either in executive orders and
there's also soon to be an osha
regulation that requires people and the
threat the threat behind that is firing
right so if you don't get it you can you
can't work here anymore and you're gonna
potentially lose your house not be able
to food on your family so the
the employee comes in reluctantly not
wanting the vaccine but being kind of
forced into this situation of having to
get it in order to maintain their
livelihood right and put food on their
family on their table for their family
is there a informed consent issue there
right that the doctors knowing this we
should be asking right do you really
want to get this or is this because of a
work requirement right is that a
question we should be asking and finding
out whether this is a free and voluntary
consent or coerced and threatened
consent
again i may not be just the right person
to talk to because of the position that
i'm in as a pediatrician
my patient population is up to age 22 so
a mandate for work would not
particularly impact most of my patients
because most of my patients are not
employed they are typically students or
at home with their families
i whenever we do
informed consent around any uh
any procedure any medication or
treatment
we certainly want to go through and have
that thorough conversation to make sure
that
we are not feeling uncomfortable that
that person is under
uh undue pressure uh for that
but that certainly from my perspective
has more to do with a case-by-case
scenario where you really have to
pull that out from somebody is that
as that person
thought of that uh all those
conversations that you just had
we really want to make sure that you
have autonomy um in your decision making
um an informed decision uh when you make
that decision but ultimately those
those those final decisions are
something that is made
in that relationship to feel comfortable
that that is a truly informed consent
so maybe there's a question for the
medical society again i'm more concerned
about putting doctors in an untenable
situation
right where they're they're
they're giving you know giving vaccines
you know to people that are don't
necessarily are giving free free consent
they're giving coerce consent because
they have to for their job function are
we putting these doctors at risk weapons
if a doctor says okay when that's the
case i'm going to say no i'm not going
to give it to you and then what that
what does that do to the employee when
the doctor's not doing them i want to
put doctors in ethical situations where
we have problems where again there's a
coerced and threatened
you know of livelihood right making
money available food on my table versus
i know i just i believe in a vaccine and
i'm not making a statement about the
vaccine at all i'm just talking about
the the ethical obligation of a doctor
right to make sure that the consent's
free and you know free from threat or
coercion
uh it's something that we'll certainly
uh have larger discussions about with
our um our leadership uh i think one of
the things that i would go back to is
that you know if these are regulations
that are being put forth by certain
employers um at the end of the day that
is a decision that that individual
uh can make and they can certainly go to
their provider and they can discuss that
with them and then it's up to them to
like again i'm also like i guess the
point was i'm worried about the ethical
problems of the doctors and then whether
or not we're just putting in throwing
away informed consent at all and just
say no you have to do it do it and and
those kind of concerns
other questions jeff
thank you mr chair i i think i'm not
sure whether it's a question or a
comment um
i think we've addressed part of this
before that there are places of
employment out there that currently
require
vaccinations whether it be a flu
vaccination a tetanus shot
or any other form of medical care for
employment
and i'm not sure how this is any
different or how this would be coercion
i'm going to step you guys out for a
second so i can answer back so again i
think it's the broad nature of of the
mandate that's causing the issue right
so again
up until now those those uh mandates by
individual employers where we were at
the request of those employers and not
every employer did a mandate
but now we're hearing that 100 of
anybody who has 101 employees
have to do a mandate right so that can
severely limits job function right the
ability for citizens to go get jobs
right in the case of the of the federal
executive order um
they're threatening medicare medicaid
money for hospitals right so again or a
hospital might be
more
accommodating now they're no longer more
accommodating because now we have
significant amount of money in the case
of dartmouth college multi-millions
dollars worth of federal money would be
impacted if they don't implement the
broad forced mandate right so i think
that the difference is that in our
workforce environment is that we're
actually now starting to limit where
people can go work because of this
mandate right where before there was
more not every every employee did it
employer did it and now even if you're
under 101 and you're a federal
contractor so um you know some small
manufacturing companies up in the lakes
region right you know i got phone calls
from that were concerned about the
mandate right they don't want to
implement them but they're being forced
to because they have federal contracts
and it's a significant portion of their
of their income so now employers who
before had options to say no we're not
going to do this are no longer given
options and so now employees can't go to
another manufacturer within lakes region
to do something so i think it's the
nature of the broad aspect of the
mandate
and the fact that it's limiting people's
ability to move from job to job because
everyone's requiring it because of a
federal requirement or federal mandate
so i think that impacts citiz our
citizenry right
that's why it's conversation right
that's why we're having these
discussions is because i can't go from
oncology to podiatry that may not
require the vaccine because now
everybody requires the vaccine due to a
federal mandate and so that that's
concerning that we're limiting our
ability for our citizenry to to pursue
their their life's passion their life's
work that's all i think that's why we're
having this conversation i think that's
why consent is important is because we
are limiting where people can go by
these mandates um because it's so broad
good feel free to respond if it just may
it's
healthcare already requires flu vaccines
we've heard from numerous hospitals
so
that limits
a nurse or a doctor or healthcare worker
into getting a flu vaccine yearly if
they want to participate in that
workforce and i'm not sure how they
differentiate
where you're going with this as to that
and whether you're in a profession that
requires something or not
it's it's it's similar are they being
coerced because they can't go anywhere
else
so again not every every i guess and
maybe the new hampshire society can can
answer to this but again not every
medical office required but now if
they're taking medicare medicaid money
they must
right so again i could have found a
doctor that says i'm not going to do the
requirement
right but now we're putting a financial
stress on those doctor's office if they
don't do a financial requirement so it's
a thumb on the scale issue right so the
federal government's put a thumb on the
scale and so where there might have been
safe havens for people who wanted to go
work in hospitals or places that
performed regular everyday you know
medicare medical work
those are going away and i think that's
the conversation point right is is that
there are no safe harbors anymore right
if i a doctor has to be willing to give
up money
in order just not to
um require the vaccine and i'm not even
sure that he can do that
without potentially having losing his
license
right and so again it's the overreaching
mandate that causes these discussions um
and the fact that i agree with you if in
a given situation it was hospital by
hospital choice
to put a mandate in then an employee can
just leave and go to another hospital
doesn't have the mandate or go to
another area that didn't have the
mandate but that's not what we're doing
anymore right that's not the case
anymore it's 100 coverage that's the
conversation right is that um there are
no more safe harbors for our for our
nurses and doctors right there are no in
in our in our manufacturing plant here
in new hampshire there's a significant
portion of the of the uh of the um
manufacturing have some sort of federal
contracts that now they're obligated to
follow a mandate and so now even the
manufacturing industry we're starting to
limit where people can move and perform
and do their job right
get get get an income to put food on the
table i think that's the conversation
point that we're talking about when we
talk about medical interventions and
enforced medical interventions by
government
um is how how do we
how do we deal with that the fact that
we're limiting where our our citizenry
can work and how does and and is that a
role of government to force or is it
should it be left to the individuals as
it was before all before this all
occurred it was up to the individual the
individual business owner to say i want
to do a mandate or i don't and that's
now no longer the case we don't have a
state law that says hospitals must do
the flu vaccine we don't have that rule
that's a hospital's choice but now we
have other rules that are being forced
so i think that's why we're having this
discussion
i'll do it in a different
aspect
we require certain vaccinations
for children
if they
enter um the education when they go to
school
is it coercion for those parents to have
to take their kids to get vaccinated
because they want because it's a
requirement for them to be in school
it's no different we require it for
school you can't go
whether in public or private school you
have to follow the guidelines for
immunizations for children
and senator bradley wants to come and i
don't think it's any different
senator of course
please answer his question real quick so
to answer your question is we recognize
that but we also have provided for an
exemption within statute so we created
the mandate but we also allowed people
to opt out
right and and we allow that in state law
under another chapter within the 141c
statutes right so it's not coercion
because parents who are opposed to it
have an option
and so there is the problem is again the
same kind of same kind of argument is
that we're doing this now for 1.3
million new hampshire residents right
and where they can work
and so and there aren't a lot of options
for opting out and yeah and especially
when we have
other areas of federal government saying
we're going to start questioning some of
the exemptions that are being granted
you know again we're limiting new
hampshire as a pretty broad and easy
exemption exemption out for students
in this case we don't necessarily have
that for what's being pushed down
that's all
senator bradley go ahead
uh thank you very much doctor
so
um
yesterday the food and drug
administration approved um
i think it was the
pfizer vaccine yeah moderna one of the
other
four
five-year-olds to um
11 year old previously had been approved
were the four phases of trials
adhered to
because i think one of the questions
that many people have had about this is
that
normally for a vaccine to be approved to
take several years of trials
to determine its efficacy and safety
so i'm just curious about that for the
childhood vaccination sure
so uh yes on tuesday uh the acip which
is that component of the cdc met after
uh the fda approved licensing for under
eua on thursday for the pfizer vaccine
the pfizer vaccine for kids five to 11
is a 10 microgram dose which is lower
than the adult dose that was uh
previously released under eua and then
officially
approved
that did go through the four phases
and those trials have been going on the
clinical trials in the setting of
looking at patients to enroll started at
least in march i know that's when i
enrolled my children in the trials
unfortunately they didn't get called
but that's been going on for quite some
time
as you go through these uh trials there
are a variety of statistical components
that go into this to ensure that you
have enough
uh data to draw a conclusion
that helps to determine the end point of
a study
as well as
to ensure that you're not doing harm
either by administering the treatment of
involved or by limiting the treatment
involved and in fact with some of these
studies particularly with one of the
moderna studies they showed the
efficacy to be so high that they stopped
the trial early
because it was showing harm not to offer
it to people
so no all four of those phases
did continue uh through that the five to
11 year old group
again was submitted right at the end of
september with that data there's been
ongoing studies
with both pfizer and moderna as well
since that early spring time for kids
six months and up and those are ongoing
trials
the speed with which this has come to
market has been a couple of different
things i think one
there's been a lot more publicity and
knowledge about it i don't think anybody
has known about the acip more than they
have now
there has been a lot of information the
way this vaccine the specifically the
mrna vaccine so the pfizer madonna
vaccines are created is a little bit
different than some of our other
vaccines the technology's been around
for about 20 years
and it really hasn't come to the general
market because we just haven't had a
virus that would be appropriately
targeted by these vaccines but they've
been around for a couple decades
uh you know mers and sars and some of
these other uh viruses have burned out
really quickly and so we just haven't
seen that in our general population
potentially in the military in other
parts of the world but not here in the
general population united states
the way this works is typically during
vaccine production
in this scenario you have a number of
steps the last step which is a very slow
step is creating the protein that your
body is going to recognize as a foreign
so that you can then your immune system
can see that and create a response
prior to this mrna vaccine technology
that last step has happened in a petri
dish in a lab so you had to infect cells
have them make a
protein harvest that protein
and then administer that protein
what happens now is that with this mrna
vaccine you're getting the recipe for
the protein
that recipe that mrna is there it gets
read by your ribosomes that make the
protein and like every other protein
mrna recipe in your body is subsequently
destroyed it then presents that protein
your body sees that says hey this
doesn't belong and makes that our immune
response so some of the time frame has
been that production of this has been
due to just the shortening process of
actually having to make this vaccine
because of the way that it works
but
the information around
the phases of study has absolutely been
uh complied with
i hope that's
so
in looking at the
um
statute that we passed last year
representative lang's bill
um
and i don't know if
you feel you can answer this or mike you
feel you can answer this but i i guess i
would post the question anybody in the
room
the way it
my question i guess is
now that the fda has approved
people between the age of 5 and 11
does the commissioner of the department
of health and human services have the
authority
to mandate
as a precondition of
attending school
getting
that covered shot
given
the
statute that we passed last year
so uh independent of that uh because my
understanding is no because it is under
emergency youth use authorization and
the
hospitals association can probably speak
to that as well
that differentiation between emergency
use authorization the eua and a full
approval
has made a significant difference in
terms of the ability to make those
mandatory
so at this point with 5 to 11 as well as
12 to 18 which would be your general
school population there's not a vaccine
that is no longer is not um out of that
eua period um so my understanding is
that no they could not make that
mandatory at this time
with regard to when that comes into play
in this bill
i struggled a little bit as i read it i
was concerned that that
the bill as i read it allowed for uh
covert vaccine and the ones that we
already have currently standing in the
state uh to potentially no longer be
required
but somebody who has a little more
legalese than i do
i think that the way the
language was written
that
the paragraph two refers to paragraph
one which talks about natural and
inherent rights and then paragraph two
says paragraph one shall not
supersede the requirement for
vaccination as a prerequisite for
admission to a school or child care
agency pursuant rsa 141
so
there is a process in place as i
understand it
mandate certain vaccinations for as a
precondition
i'm glad you pointed out the eua
provision
for adults i think it's it's advisor or
moderna that has gone beyond the ua but
adults only yeah so fives are just for
adults only my understanding is it's
just the 18 and up pfizer
has received that full approval so right
now for our pediatric patients it's all
under that emergency youth use
authorization and so therefore uh would
not be able to be made mandatory in any
of those settings and schools or
employers okay so at this point in time
um
the commissioner because of the e
the emergency use authorization
it could not be mandated for five to 11
year olds all right
i think um just as a
sort of a general issue for all the
legal beagles in this room and those
that aren't in this room
having clarity on the
law
and what could or maybe couldn't and i'm
not taking a position one way or the
other at this point but i just the
understanding of
what your language and your bill allows
or doesn't allow vis-a-vis
an update to the statute will be
interesting so
i guess i'd
invite people to opine on that
you know you can get back to us
electronically i think that would be a
useful discussion
especially given the fact that we have
55 vaccine bills that you folks are
going to you know deal with before they
come to us
thank you you're welcome too you're down
to 32 yeah
um any other questions for the new
hampshire medical society
i i would ask that maybe the medical
society consider that conversation we
just had about informed consent and free
and fair informed consent maybe get back
with our email um you know and how how
that plays out because that's a really
of interest to me and how positions
you know are being stuck in a kind of a
bad spot and how we can either
potentially fix that or not or or how
that can be dealt with
yeah mr chair sorry that i was not quick
enough with my hand i actually had
another question for dr johnson
um thank you for all of the information
that you presented and especially
recognizing the difference between the
eua and the full approval
and your compassion for your patients
especially those ones at higher risk
because maybe they're publicly insured
or they have cancer
i wasn't sure how deeply you follow the
science but i don't know if you're aware
that there's a study that was in the
journal of clinical oncology
from emily johnston of the institute for
cancer outcomes and survivorship in
alabama so they followed 917 pediatric
cancer patients
there were 44 percent hispanic 59
publicly insured 66 with hematologic
malignancies
it actually was quite fascinating
45 of them needed their cancer therapy
modified
but when you looked to what actually
happened you had um for hospitalization
there was a risk of one sorry
when you look at the hospitalization
rates you look at the death rates there
was only one point there were here we go
here it is there were 10 percent that
needed respiratory support 9.2 admitted
to the icu and 1.6 percent died due to
sars coveted infection um and there
actually was an underlying study when
they were looking at disparity in care
for a very similar patient population
and in that where they identified that
hispanics have lower outcomes in cancer
that study also showed a 1.6 death rate
from cancer over that same time period
so it's actually really heartening to
know that even our pediatric pediatric
oncology patients still do well as
children because children's outcomes are
better than adults sure
just to speak to that uh it's very
interesting and as we look at these
studies that's not one i'm particularly
familiar with but
i think something that we've noticed in
our practice on a regular basis are the
consequences of some of those underlying
risk factors
many of those children who are at high
risk for their own reasons or for family
members reasons elected last year to do
their learning from home and not to be
in school uh they elected uh not to
leave their house uh by the families who
literally did not leave the house for
nine months um that has a significant
impact as well and unfortunately those
are things that are really challenging
for us to measure
what those outcomes are whether that's a
mental health outcome an educational
outcome
for that individual child
for that family as we look at the
consequences of the behaviors that they
may have put in place to keep themselves
safe
and while i'm so excited to hear that
those numbers are as reassuring as they
are
i do really have very valid concerns i
think for those uh changes that people
experience to be able to attain those
outcomes
uh with avoiding things that we know are
really important for children and their
development
thank you and i actually do have one
comment on the speed of development of
the vaccines
back when i was a device analyst i went
to a vaccine
conference about developing a vaccine
for the next pandemic
we were right after the first sars and
it was quite fascinating but there were
some things where they expanded the
pediatric vaccine registry and the adult
administration so we'd have
manufacturing capacity so it's been a
multifaceted approach it's something
that they've been working on for many
years and it's quite fascinating that
people have the opportunity to have
vaccines so early in this it's just uh
wanting to respect the potential side
effects as well where people do want
to have respect for that personal
autonomy if their risk factors are high
enough or they have their religious or
medical reasons so that's why it's such
a challenging discussion but such an
important one to have so thank you
you're welcome it certainly is a a
challenge i think just to speak to that
to help reassure folks it's a common
conversation we have in my practice
the way that we receive information
around vaccine side effects has also
changed pretty dramatically with this uh
vaccine rollout in the last year
for
for all people who have received this
vaccine they have an opportunity to
participate
in the v safe program through the
cvc
and that has allowed people to give
feedback very directly in real time for
how they are doing after vaccine
classically you've had to make a formal
report to
some entity at the federal level about a
concern that you had
right now
i've been getting since i just got my
booster a week ago i've been getting
daily text messages from vsafe saying
how are you feeling today
and it gives you that opportunity to say
you know my elbows are kind of achy this
is weird it probably has nothing to do
with this vaccine but my elbows hurt so
my elbows hurt uh so we've been able to
collect data in a very different way
here in the us than we ever have before
and i think it helps me feel more
confident that when we look for trends
we have that information from what we're
doing here in the united states i have
often uh related
referred my patients back to some of the
scandinavian studies where they collect
data very differently
in terms of being able to search their
medical record directly as part of how
their health care system works
where they can collect data
in real time and look retrospectively
more easily
but i really think that the v safe data
collection has allowed much easier
accessibility and cut down those levels
of communication so that we've had
better ongoing tracking of
expected and unexpected side effects
so what you see is what you measure so i
appreciate that yeah when i had worked
with the drug-eluting stents they
started stunting everything with it once
they had a coating so you didn't need
the therapy but unfortunately once you
got off aspirin people started dying
from heart attacks because they thought
it was this fantastic situation with an
unexpected late side effect and sweden
is fantastic i definitely appreciate all
the epidemic
epidemiological data that we get from
sweden since they they collect so much
information and but we do have some
signals there from that population that
do put some people at it at pause
especially for their sons um but i think
that i think it's fantastic they're
available for people so thank you you're
welcome
any other questions of the committee
if you just follow up with me on the
informed consent question i appreciate
it and thank you very much thank you
i think that oplc show up we had
somebody who called me last night said
they were going to be here today from
and
anybody else who would like to testify
for the healthcare or business
communities
on this topic
[Music]
okay
let me move to a general discussion and
jeff i'd like i'd like to follow up
because i'm interested in just our
discussion that was going on and and if
we understand if we if we agree and
understand as to why this is an issue
right relative to
um you know again we're not talking
about necessarily just the health care
field we have you know 1.3 million new
hampshire citizens that we're here to
represent and discuss and and help
um
i guess i'm just interested in your
comments as the back and forth that we
were having and discussing i don't want
we can probably i guess agree to
disagree that i'm not sure there's
really a fact of coercion in there that
there are a number of places where
vaccines are required and i'm i just
don't see
that
coming into play
okay
any other comments from the committee
representative shaw
i have a slightly different
perspective on that
i think that
um
a general overall
mandate
of you must have a vaccination
um
has its drawbacks because
it's also it's creating
um
hardships
for some people
it's creating
um problems in the workforce it's
creating
divide among
families and people
a right to choose
if a person is not vaccinated and
doesn't choose to be vaccinated
but they wear a mask and they follow
safety protocols
the person that they're
most endangering is themselves
and to me
um
i feel
i feel the same way about seat belts i
feel the same way about
other things like that that
you
if it's your choice
if you have someone else in the car it's
a different situation maybe you're
you know you're creating a problem for
that person
but
i i
there's so many unknowns even a doctor
will tell you in a conversation
that there are still
a lot of unanswered questions
about the vaccine
um it hasn't been in effect long enough
to really make long-term decisions
a vaccine like pooping for whooping
cough and pertussis and measles mumps
pox those those vaccines that the kids
get
uh are proven over
10 12
14 years
but it took probably 30 years to figure
out that
measles was coming back on some of the
kids that
that
had been vaccinated so they should have
a booster
but not
in a matter of five months or six months
and all of a sudden
you know this this is becoming a vaccine
uh
mandate
where
the
studies and the the
progress
has not covered enough variety of people
some people never get sick
no matter what they just don't get sick
they've never had vaccines they don't go
to a doctor
and they're fine
other people
go to doctors they they're constantly
having
different shots for different things
because they know that their body
is susceptible because they have a
an immune system that's that's
compromised
but they
have a choice
to make that decision
and
that's where i have a problem
with
a mandate
i think a
suggested the suggested safety measures
are the where we should have stopped and
not gone with a mandate
for employment
if you work in a specific
um
type of an environment
and part of the
and you know
as part of your job
that you need to have
x y and z
and you take that job knowing this
that's a different story
but when you
are in a
position
as
a legislature legislator as a
um
just
i i can't think of other
positions
at the moment but that's irrelevant it's
it's a
a violent something that should be
voluntary
according to a person's choice
and i feel strongly about that
and i i think if you are
uh
some people just choose to avoid
other people
and they don't want to get a vaccine but
they don't go anywhere they stay
isolated in their home and they might be
retired or
or something like that
so
and and i don't see how an unvaccinated
person
can be
any more of a threat than a person who's
vaccinated because of
breakthrough
cases
that have come from people who are
vaccinated
and that's just my opinion and uh i had
it
it was my own fault i didn't get the
vaccine
and but
i never had a flu shot
in my life
one time i decided to do it
and i had the worst winter of my life in
illness because my body doesn't need it
and and
in this particular case
i had had an operation last summer
and i had internal bleeding created a
problem with my body that i wasn't used
to i never
never had any type of thing like that
and then
i was run down i had a lot of issues
that happened with my normal asthma for
a couple months
and whammo when i decided i think i'm
going to go get the
vaccine
i got it before i had to chance so i had
to deal with it
but i fought it and i was lucky and god
decided he wasn't i wasn't ready
for my eternal life and i was happy
about that
and um but
i still think it's choice and i made
that choice i made a wrong choice at the
time
now i'm having problems
were be worrying about being up here
and having to have a mandate that in
order to be in the legislature you have
to have a shot and i don't know if i
want it yet
the when i heard
the doctor she's gone now she she
mentioned
um
that
gave me a different perspective about
the vaccine because she said that
the vaccine itself which i have been
thinking
had been only
um
you know studied for a few months
actually had been studied for quite a
one thing that wasn't
in there was the particular protein
that was going to
affect this particular virus and that's
what they had to come up with and they
did but they had already had
a
one for sars mrsa
you know things like that but were not
as widespread
as the cloven 19 became so that's an
interesting point but i've also read in
from medical doctors in europe
who
say that there are
effects
that that up to at least 12 months
of immunity for people who have had
coveted with their antibodies to prevent
them from
getting the the disease and if they do
get it again it would be a lesser
um
case
in the case of kids going to school
those
uh
vaccines
had years and years and years of study
before they were mandated in the schools
and i would not want them to go away
and and because i think they're
important um those diseases are not fun
to go through and i was in a generation
that didn't get those shots and had
everything from the whooping cough all
the way up to chickenpox just name it i
had it
but i so i just think
that um
you know having a just a blanket mandate
from the federal government
is wrong
and i and i think that it should be left
up to
the
um
the individual
uh companies
and the uh the individuals themselves
uh to
decide
uh what
should be required and what should not
and not call it a mandate
thank you thank you representative
i will just make a couple comments
relative to you know i'm with you into a
certain extent about mandates although
you know
would it be so that i could wave the
magic wand and the federal government
would change its policy
but that's just not likely to happen
um
the the one thing that's interesting is
and i want to call a couple of tensions
as people looking at data and talking
about this topic is that
in recent news we've heard that the the
dashboard for the dhhs has some problems
if you look at the number of
vaccinations reported
in new hampshire is 800 000 and change
if you look at the new hampshire state
website however if you look at the cdc
website which commissioner shibanet said
is more accurate because of reporting
issues
it's over a million people in new
hampshire have already been vaccinated
to some degree
and so the interesting part about this
conversation is the fact that
prior to covet new hampshire was one of
the most immunized states in the country
because people just chose to right they
lived for united states they made their
decision they chose to get it and it's
only now that we're having dissent and
and and concerned because we're now
forcing where we've never done that
before you know to a certain extent i i
know that it's a very bad analogy and i
probably shouldn't use it but it's the
petulant child thing where we're
stomping your feet right wait i would
have done i would have cleaned my room
anyway but now i'm not going to do it
because you told me to do it right and
so we're having a little bit of that
going on right
and so
uh you know i guess this conversation is
happening around that is that we've had
it's never been stigmatized before if
you chose not to
right and now we're stigmatizing it
right in this in the state but now we're
calling it out and we're where you know
and that is of concern as we as we
divide up our population right into the
haves and have-nots you got it i don't
i'm not you know therefore i'm not going
to do this so you can't do that right
and so that's around some of these
discussion points we're having right now
is is the the it's never been an issue
before in immunization right is that
we've always had a high
i hate to use the word compliance but
voluntary compliance with getting
vaccinations
and now we're seeing pushback right
because even the people that before
we've accepted the fact that they chose
not to get the flu shot or get whatever
other shots are out there that are done
um i was asked the other day was the
last shot i got i couldn't remember um
you know because it's not something i
even think about i think that's true for
most people they don't think about the
last time they got a shot or an
immunization unless they're standing in
their doctor's office but now we're
calling it front and center and it's
dividing our state it's dividing our
citizens right and and and we can either
stand by as legislators and do nothing
right or we can try to figure out what
the fix is you know so again where
where can we make it easier for our
citizens to get along through and deal
with these mandates right and so in
terms of businesses you know i i want i
don't want businesses to be put between
a rock and a hard spot you know where
they're dealing with i got a federal
mandate and i got a workforce and
they're they're there at odds with each
other
right so how can us as a state
legislator legislature fix that right
how can we ease that odds so the
workforce and the businesses can just go
about doing their business right without
these uh without a workforce issue right
and so you know and jeff back to your
point where before it was all voluntary
right it's no longer voluntary so the
ones that had the mandates don't feel
any change but the ones that didn't have
the mandates are feeling changed and
there may have been a
a strong business reason because they
knew they had a population of workers
that were that didn't want to get the
vaccine and they chose not to do a
mandate because their workforce it's
more important to have the people there
than to have the people quit because of
a mandate right and so they chose that
but now we're not doing not giving them
choice
and so again it's how can we help our
businesses how can we help our doctors
again i i'm
i'm really worried
i i truly am worried about that ethical
concern for a doctor right that that the
fact that yeah in certain circumstances
they were doing it because of a job
function and and the employee wanted it
but now we're literally firing people
that have never been fired before that
have been in their job for 20 and 30
years but because
they refuse to get injected right i mean
i probably wouldn't even have this
argument if you can tell me how to
unvaccinate somebody right but there is
no unvaccination right you can't undo
what's been done right and so people
have a serious legitimate concern in
their mind
and for us to step into that all right
and tell them no i don't care what your
legitimate concern is if you want to put
food on your table you have to do this
right and so and that's a forced
situation so again as a legislature i
think part of this committee is talking
about those kind of things how do we
resolve that conflict between our
citizens and the mandates and how do we
help our businesses and our health care
providers right that are stuck between
this rock and a hard spot
right they gotta comply with the federal
mandate
they have a workforce that's resistant
and even if it's only ten percent like i
said i have manufacturing industry in
the lakes region two people two
businesses call me saying i'm subject to
this thing i'm gonna lose 10 of my
workforce if i lose 10 of my workforce i
can't meet the federal contracts because
i don't have people to hire
right and so and
what did they do
how do they manage that
right and and what can we do as a
legislator make it easier for them
um
so i guess that's why we're having this
meeting and i guess that's a you know
it's great that senator bradley put the
committee on there right not you know i
guess i guess he had a little crystal
ball he knew this was coming up you know
and was able to see what was going on um
but you know those are my comments to
this is that how do we mitigate this and
how do we fix this um i i do think there
is a problem myself
in how we deal and how our citizens are
going to have to deal with this and how
our businesses have to deal with this
go ahead jeff
thank you mr chair
i just may respond a little bit to that
as we talk about
executive orders and federal mandates um
[Music]
we heard yesterday
that there was very little we could do
on a state level with the federal
mandate
so the question comes back to
if it's a federal mandate i'm not sure
what this committee can do on a state
level
to go around that mandate other than
what our attorney general is doing and
it's taking it to court or filing
in with the other states
sure so again i think you heard the
attorney general say that or or um and
edwards the assistant attorney general
who is here says that
in a court case the um court in a in a
preemptive challenge like this of a
supremacy clause looks at the will of
the state and by passing a law even if
it isn't enforceable it still states the
will of the state that we don't believe
in federal mandates right and that the
court could use that in its
determination in in the in their in
their case that's what she said right
that it does help in that it provides
direction to the court as to what the
will of the state is
right so i i think that even if it's is
unenforceable it is useful to the state
potentially to pass something right i'll
give you another example and it's going
to be all self-servings it's my bill but
creating an easier exemption clause for
businesses right so they're not stuck in
this i have to decide whether somebody's
religious enough and then i'm gonna have
the federal government come in behind me
to check to see
if i was um
uh diligent enough
in pursuing these exemptions to make
sure they're valid
right is that we could pass a simple
state law that eases exemptions right
that makes it easier for business to
provide an exemption so they could still
impose a mandate but then still have um
have clear law and say that says there's
an exemption law in new hampshire i got
to follow it so i i did a mandate and
but i also followed the state law with
the exemptions so they can fix we could
fix that make it easier for them to be
able to retain workers by allowing for
easier exemptions
right
that would be allowable and so there's a
case of we've met the federal mandate
and we've met state law so there are
places we can go to make it easier for
businesses and easier for doctors
to manage um so i i think it's it's not
like being said well they need us
federal government we got to walk away i
don't think that's a legitimate answer i
think there are places we can fix stuff
and that we should follow
so i guess that's my answer to your
question
of legal thank you mr chairman i agree
with that as well my takeaway from the
assistant attorney general's comments
were that um if it is the will of the
legislature in the state that we do
provide some protection for these
employers and these employees
and potentially customers that this
extends further but if we allow these
protections that then that will help
strengthen our case in order to figure
out where that line of interaction
between the federal and state will end
up falling so it's not a head-on
challenge to
ease ease these challenge these problems
because
we we right now if you've seen any of
the religious exemption forms coming
especially southwest
here's all these answers if you don't
answer these completely truthfully
you're fired and i'd like to talk to
your pastor so i can ask them
independently that that may be going too
far i know that there's some other
places that may be challenged for not
going far enough by the federal
government and that's a very challenging
position for our businesses to be in
um we actually the osha law has come out
while we've been here in this committee
so i'm hopeful that we'll have a chance
to maybe hear back at some point i don't
know i defer to you mr chairman on that
about the interpretation of that osha
law and i did want to agree with
representative shaw's opinions as well
on this i think that that mandating
things is a lot different than making
them available and encouraged and i want
to provide a little bit more backstory
on those vaccines
there's been a process in order to
accelerate them
but this is an entirely novel vaccine
therapy a new way of doing things
if we had stayed with traditional
vaccine technologies just not in the
amplification of the protein but the
whole process it would have been about
two years so we still wouldn't have any
vaccine available for anybody which
would be a tragedy because
it's it's a blessing that we have these
available to us today but it is still
relatively new and and we're finding
things out as we go along and i knew i
do know that what used to be a
relatively small field of virology is uh
we're going to have a lot new science
and a lot of new scientists who have
been inspired by this to bring the next
vaccines
so just to answer your question on the
osha thing so yeah the white house just
came out with the release of the
requirement it says the osha rule
requires employers 100 or more to put
vaccine requirements in place for all
staff or face fines up to fourteen
thousand dollars per violation
um
additionally they also pushed back the
implementation date to january 4th to
give a little more breathing room to
businesses so
um and it was done as part of the
emergency temporary standards of osha
that they're allowed to do
so um so we kind of have a place to look
now to see what's coming down the pike
and again this the same requirement is
is sitting on top of all of our federal
contractors anybody who receives
medicare medicaid money um are also
subject to the executive order which is
on top of the osha order so uh good
conversation points
anything else senator bradley anything
from you
well
i guess this is more a
procedural question
we're having a public hearing on monday
right
and
i think
we're meeting on wednesday as a
committee after that
wednesday actually we've opened it up
for another public hearing but if we
don't need it then we'll go do so
committee work session
it depends on what happens on monday
so i mean what is
you know with 32 bills dealing with
vaccines
discuss the purpose of
you know this committee i'm wondering
what
the ultimate goal here
um
if the purpose of the
[Music]
study was to look at medical
intervention broader than
vaccines and i think that was something
you would articulate it
um
i
i understand where
there might be a desire for
an lsr to be submitted
virtually all of the discussion that
we've had and i apologize for having to
leave early yesterday and gotten here a
little late today
um
all the discussion i've heard has all
been vaccine policy i'm just
posing the question
with 32 bills
does this committee need to make a
recommendation that would develop a
33rd lsr
so thank you another for your question
so again not not prejudging where we're
going to get to
um
you know i did ask and i had a
conversation with dhhs they're going to
go back
they didn't they're going to expand
their search
um because again i had the conversation
about any medical intervention and rules
were in law and they're going to go back
and get us that data
they weren't ready for to talk to us
yesterday and they were a little bit
more narrow in their discussion and so
we've had that conversation with them
they are going to come back what i'm i'm
anticipating
is that again depending on how monday's
public hearing goes if we need more room
another day for more public comment
because people still want to speak then
i want to give everybody an opportunity
to speak um
i i will again i'm going to caution just
like i've i said in other places we're
sticking to policy and not people
right so this is not about how someone
handled somebody so we're not going
after people but we're going over the
policy for the state and to keep it on
policy um so on monday depending on as
people speak about policy if it if if it
seems like we still have a list of
people that want to speak we're going to
move on to wednesday and we'll have
another public session during the day on
on wednesday to allow more people to
speak
um and then ultimately after that
we'll probably come back for one meeting
to discuss with the agencies again one
more time because we've asked them to go
back and look at their rules and
regulations and look for that
intersections of shells and shall not
set existing current state law
and then we'll meet and i think we'll
hammer out what we want to do whether or
not it's an lsr or whether or not it's
just a general statement you know again
we're going back to the attorney
generals there seems to be a valid
reason why maybe we want to encourage
something to pass
to give the state a position if that is
our position about the mandate
um
so i i think that you know it may just
be a general statement that says that
here's a couple lsrs that are of
interest and
it's according to the attorney general
it's a good idea to pass kind of thing
to to make our will known to the federal
government as a state legislature and
as a state of new hampshire if the
governor should sign it um it'll
strengthen their case so i guess that's
procedurally we have two days of public
hearing maybe one more day of admit of
of
coming back with i asked the new
hampshire medical society to try to
chase down the information about
informed consent and and the feeling of
their will of their people we asked
chess to come back with some data um uh
dave i think you were going to come back
with some information as well so we may
come back for one more hearing now
people give fill in the gaps that they
that we for questions we asked and then
i think we move on to discussion as to
you know the committee report can be
current state law seems to be fine and
there's really nothing we need to do or
maybe here's some recommendations on
changes in legislation um i i'm not
going to go there until i hear all of
the testimony because i don't know
what's going to come out but well that
may be there's nothing for nothing to do
at this point again there's all kinds of
options there
and i think we take that up in probably
anything else is there anybody else in
the room who wants to speak
come on up
just state your name and
can you hear me
thanks hi i'm abby rogers i'm the
legislative liaison for the division of
public health services um i just wanted
to provide some information regarding
senator bradley's question about whether
the commissioner has authority to
approve a vaccination for child
child care or school entry that's not
fda approved
the the commissioner does have authority
through rulemaking through rsa 140 141
ca 20a
to
adopt rules relative to immunizations
for child care or school injury if
necessary um the department doesn't have
any plans to do that at this time unless
required a law would require us to do so
but i just want to provide that
clarification and there's a clarifying
question to your clarifying information
sure but that doesn't apply to an eua
vaccine if um if i understand that i
think by federal law nobody can mandate
uh an eu related you know something
under emergency use authorization nobody
can mandate that that it has to be
fully a fully vetted vaccine from the
fda before a mandate could be implied
right there's nothing in the new
hampshire statute that has any
indication about sort of an fda approval
however
specifically i think there's an lsr this
in in this yeah there is an lsr that
talks about that yeah i just wanted to
provide that clarification that we do
have rulemaking authority yes thank you
you're welcome
senator i'm not sure i heard everything
so i want to make sure i
understand it
um
in order for there to be a new
hampshire-based
mandate for attending school or daycare
the commissioner would have to
initiate a rulemaking proceeding that's
correct
now would the commissioner have the
authority under the emergency rule
making proceeding to go through without
it being
fully approved
by gel car
it would have to be approved by jail car
yes it would have to be approved by gel
car because the emergency rule allows
i believe i've never sat on gel car but
i believe it's a six month
emergency temporary rule
um to go forward without full gel car
approval
correct right so i think that um if
there was an emergency rule that would
have a different qualification but my
understanding is that she does the
commissioner does have rule making
authority if it was an emergency role
would go through that standard procedure
of the emergency rulemaking
for child care and school entry right so
the commissioner could
order
mandatory vaccines if it was
not under eua authority
under an emergency rule
okay that's how i understand it yes does
the commissioner
have the authority now to order vaccines
or
i think is it the age of 18 or 16.
uh i believe with consent i mean for any
school requirement there needs to be
vaccines um you know to enter to enter
school so that would start at the age of
three
um with consent from parents of course
but there she could separate i mean they
could said uh the commissioner could
adopt rules requiring additional
vaccines for school or child care entry
at any time through rulemaking
but with a rulemaking proceeding correct
you're 141 um c20 c20-a but we don't
tend to do that unless required by by
statute at this point
wait a minute i didn't get that last
part oh sorry we're not intending to um
mandate a coveted vaccine in schools
unless there was a law suggesting that
we do that all right so the so the the
bottom line here if i'm understanding
you correctly what you just said there
is no
thought at this point in time by the
department of health and human services
absent a new law being passed to mandate
for school-aged children any vaccine the
covenant 19 vaccines 19 yes i'm sorry
yes that's correct that's correct that's
correct okay i just wanted to clarify
that
senator that would be a while to get to
the clarification but i think
i understand it and i suspect that
you know for people that are watching us
online i appreciate your uh
your answer of course thank you
so senator having been punished by the
speaker and been on jail car for the
last three terms um i will say that uh
the emergency orders do come before
jalcar we just have no there's no vote
taken we don't vote on them they're just
prince presented to jalcar and we can
ask questions about it um but we can't
do anything about it if they if they
would implement but i'm glad to hear
that dhhs the commission has no in uh
inclination to right now put a covet 19
anything else to come before the
committee
all right there being none will be in
the german we're meeting on monday at
nine o'clock in reps hall
thank you everybody for coming thank you
for your testimony if you have any
follow-up stuff my email address is
timothy.lang lag.state.nh.us
most of you have it feel free to send
any follow-up information to that
and i appreciate everybody coming
[Music]
you know that i'm unavailable after
next wednesday
so wednesday
so
whatever you want to
yeah
you have to have a i think it's a
december first death
well you
you want to go without a form i have no
problem with that
you